so the Democrats have all been
pretending that they're poor and I'm not
just talking about the regular Democrats
I'm talking about the power people
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden in
particular Hillary of course is going to
run in 2016 Biden may run which i think
would kind of be fun in a Naked Gun way
but also kind of scary so we did this
two weeks ago Hillary talking about how
poor she is and she was us we've got two
clips on her I one on Biden so let's
watch Hillary talking about her
struggles it has been reported you've
made five million making speeches the
president made more than a hundred
million dollars well if you you have no
reason to remember but we came out of
the White House not only dead broke but
in debt we had no money when we got
there and we struggled to you know piece
together the resources for mortgages for
houses for Chelsea's education you know
it was not easy okay that's utter
nonsense and total [ __ ] so basically
she's saying we came in with nothing not
true i mean they had money he was the
governor of arkansas bill and then they
left completely broke they needed money
for houses houses how many houses do you
have so i'm pretty sure they're doing
okay i'm pretty sure there's no
restaurant that they've ever been turned
away from but she continued first of all
we had to pay off all our debts which
was you know you had to make double the
money because of obviously taxes and
then pay off the debts and get us houses
and take care of family members but do
you think americans gonna understand
five times the median income in this
country for one speech well let me put
it this way i thought making speeches
for money was a much better thing than
getting connected with any one group or
company as so many people who leave
public life do because she's so much
better than those people who take money
from one she did take four hundred
thousand to do two speeches from goldman
sachs and i'm not progressing her any of
this you're allowed to make money this
is america that's great but don't
pretend that you have no money nor
access to making money in the future and
then Joe Biden here we go now the first
thing is you
sailing Biden man he's got he got a a
mildly expensive suit huh he's vice
president nited states america he makes
notwithstanding these lettuces of the
forest man in Congress he still makes a
lot of money as vice president nine
states and i do by the way I do
don't hold it against me they don't know
that I don't own a single stock or bond
don't hold it I have no savings account
but I got a great pension and I got a
good salary and foreal I mean I'm
telling you his presidency would be
frank drebin from a guy ok he is
flat-out lying he does have a savings
account and he does have 11 investment
funds there in his wife's name so yes
technically I suppose he's not lying but
he's lying so where I want to start with
this I don't progress' these guys
success I want people to be running the
country that know how to do their
finances so hopefully they can help the
finances of the country what is the
fascination with pretending they're poor
and struggle they want to relate to the
American people because you know they
feel like that's gonna help them get
elected and you know increase their
approval ratings and stuff but I don't
understand why it's so hard to be like I
wasn't always as successful but now I've
done better Hillary could have said that
I mean I know that she was being asked
questions so I kind of you her situation
a little bit differently yeah I'm Biden
cuz Biden's just I mean no one's asking
him anything he's just like I don't have
a savings account and I mean it's just
kind of like ridiculous and like you
said it's a flat oh I why can't they you
know be honest and say you know I can
relate because I was once in that
position you know now I've come out of
that but to sit there and lies it's not
gonna help right now Biden did say one
thing that was true which is that he was
when he was in the Senate he was the
poorest member in terms of having money
in the Senate but like what so he
blatantly lies there what should we do
about it Halai politician lying i can't
believe who call their asses out like it
like what you're doing here I mean this
is there they overreacted just like at
least the wrong feeling raped by the
paparazzi and group feeling like she's
at war this is your attempt at trying to
relate to the American people and it's
completely backfiring and by the way I'm
gonna do an impression of Diane Sawyer
in that clip which is this she looked
like she's about to slap the [ __ ] out of
Hillary because she's sitting here
thinking you've got to be kidding me I
know what my salary is it yours is
definitely higher and yeah
Hilary has to pay for texts and her
daughter's education oh by the way
family expenses and their and their
houses the houses how's it by the way
you know jewelry Chelsea Clinton was
also at you know just a couple years ago
two years ago given a six hundred
thousand a year job at NBC News despite
the fact that she wasn't qualified all
it was pretty terrible and they
basically paid her to do like three
appearances so so that's pretty sweet
why do we have success shame do you
think because that's what it this seems
to me I get it they want to relate to
everybody but we seem to have this real
thing where we're ashamed of wanting to
be successful or actually being
successful I think it's a carryover from
the last election I think there was so
Romney got so much flak for presuming
Lee presume is that whatever the word is
having so much money that he lost an
election he was seen as unrelatable and
out of touch and you know what to Hiller
is credit you know like at the end of
the month guys when like you paid your
rent you paid the bills you're waiting
for like the checks to come in that's
when your account is kind of in flux
I'll bet you know the with the Clintons
I'll bet you you know their accounts are
in flux by millions and millions of
dollars and there's always that one day
in the month where it might be negative
10 million like Hillary talked about but
of course she has yet to cash the rest
of the checks and so she's trying to
relate with just that oh god the 30th of
every month I just don't like that rope
I think your base that's probably it
there is probably some truth to that
they had right yet by the way her
campaign which in 2008 ran into debt you
know she had owners pay off her
campaigns dead so seventy dollar
t-shirts with a 70 bucks they were high
they were up there especially after she
lost her because they were collectors
items yeah seven years um so the reason
I'm doing this segment is because it
seems to me that we're always attacking
Republicans about money but I want
everyone to know that the Democrats are
just as bad do you think that's a fair
estimation I mean do you think it's fair
I mean I feel like they're trying too
hard to be relatable because they feel
like that's so important but to be
ashamed of success is really ridiculous
and I think the reason why they're doing
that is because people you know make
them in a position where being
successful could be viewed as a negative
trait in a politician because oh they'll
never be able to relate to me because
they have all this money I'm struggling
financially why would they try to go out
of their way to help me
if they can't relate more but to
flat-out lie isn't helping and for
people to even have that attitude in
society that success is a negative thing
is ridiculous i can think of hundreds
and hundreds of politicians who are a
contradiction to that I mean no one
thinks about the Senate or the house
representatives all these people who are
making a [ __ ] ton of money and no one
ever says anything about them because
all they can see are the President and
the Vice President in these people who
are so much in the public eye but
they're not the only people in politics
and they're not the only people making a
lot of money and George Bush w bush he
had a ton of money you know it would his
connections to oil and stuff and no one
ever complained about that because
they're like oh Texas and mirga and he
can relate to people blame the Democrats
complain it was pretty much an idiot and
no one cared are a lot of people
whenever he's being elected didn't care
because they were like oh he's so
relatable to us you know Texas and right
he does in Texas like a guy and he knew
how to throw a baseball remember he
threw that first pitch out to do strike
to being a president but I mean mo
temple most people who reach the level
of education that you would hope that
they would have in order to be holding
public office like that they're gonna be
in a position where they're making money
because they've reached a level of
success that other people have it right
would you rather have someone in office
who has no idea how to handle their
personal finances and is it in debt you
don't even if you knew that the guy that
was coming into president he really
[ __ ] up his financial situation you
know you mean he's got creditors calling
him that's what they somehow want this
that's what she's saying like I we were
in all we had nothing but I would never
want that person to be president right
it's sad that I think that that's the
relatable candidate though they're like
oh we must you know reach out to the
millions of Americans who are in debt
and have creditors chasing after them in
order to get through a vote yeah tragic
um last thought on this the lying part
just the flat-out lying which is what
they're both doing and I get it
Hillary's doing it a little bit less
because she sort of mincing words and
maybe debt and whatever but he's
flat-out lying cuz it's his wife that
owns this stuff and that's a lie so does
that matter even does anyone even care
when they get caught this up there yeah
i mean i don't know of how much he cares
what he should yeah cuz i mean at least
for me i'm not gonna trust somebody you
know how many people trust politicians
anyways but i mean for him to sit there
and say you know it's my wife's money
not mine i mean look at me I'm so I
don't have a savings account it's
ridiculous yeah does the lying matter to
you or do you just expect it I I think
it comes with the territory
unfortunately I think they're gonna pass
it off as you know just politics really
they told they told a little bit of a
fib where they are they sort like the
dinner party conversation where you just
say something to relate to the person
next to you just to make them feel a
little bit better and I don't honestly
think it's going to hurt them whatsoever
or their charm and personality and
celebrity status is going to get them to
the next level yeah well sadly I agree
with you they have more money than you
which is ok but you know what they're
liars so both them all out all right